hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde wir haben uns heute versammelt
denn max und ich machen eine youtuber
erraten challenge schauspieler parodien
und lauch für laute muss für laute sein
da ist das ding das tool erlaubt nur ich
selbst oder ja ich habe mich gedacht die
ganze schauspieler auch ne
zweiter youtuber meine lieben freunde
gaming ich sagt german alkohol nicht
montana black stark übergewichtigen 95
das stimmt aber ja doch der hat auch
immer gesoffen ja das kann doch nicht
sagen
twitter youtube com jetzt kommt jetzt
junge einzelhandelskaufmann
ok wir essen.de autor und montana black
sea
[Musik]
ich glaube eher das hätte ich niemals
gedacht dass er im einzelhandel aber
sich noch nicht gedacht aber auch im
sommer und punkt bekommen
der youtuber als eine marke die bisher
per agb
[Musik]
wir haben songs zusammen wir hatten kids
choice award gewonnen und sehr tief so
verstehe ich nicht also habibi ist auf
jeden fall falsch erwarten
oh mein gott dann habe ich überhaupt
nicht gerechnet da gar nicht dran
gedacht
youtuber 05 wir sind schon bei der
halbzeit von der ersten runde an
gekommen um die winzerin kommen youtube
hat sich glaube ich dir drin doch die
kriege schlechtesten gar nicht muss er
wie sein
vielleicht ist es dann auch regine
geiles foto hat sehr schönes foto und
sehr gutes foto von baby da ist es ein
sehr schönes foto von reviews ein sehr
schönes fotos andré anschauen wie wir
uns zeit unvergesslich super schönes
foto und werden weiter so sehr
ja geil schönes foto auf jeden fall ist
echt ein schönes foto von revieren der
stelle
egal wer das ist einfach ein schönes
foto da drin gehabt das stimmt ja
levy hatte ein schönes foto münster
wissen to go
das war aber noch gesprochen das ist
dann nicht habe ich schlecht bin ich
denn die christa wissen togo
er vermittelt wissen über togo
[Musik]
mir ist wichtig dass wir wieder ein
schönes foto
youtuber nummer sieben in meiner lieben
freunde haben als erstes veganes holen
dann wieder nicht alter was ein veganer
polnischer youtuber der bei [ __ ] you
goethe mitgespielt hat
ich habe keine ahnung wie sie ist nicht
vegan aber wie gerne schnitzel gab es ja
und so aber kommt die aus polen besser
da geht kommt aus polen jahr arbeitet er
mit [ __ ] you goethe zu tun die hat er
seine minis trainer am stand in seiner
pool hütte gehabt
youtuber nummer acht minecraft loos lust
hat ich glaube ich habe mich in der
nächsten runde einfach mal absichtlich
zurück armee liegen halt andere sachen
am herzen
zum beispiel release films foto
youtuber nummer 9 gang tour los du bist
mit der tube ja ja business coaching
auch klassisch ich finde wir sollten es
auch nicht darum spiel wir hier besser
ist ja und einfach mal uns darauf
verständigen dass er wie ein schönes
buch
ja ja ja ja
der letzte youtuber für die erste runde
meine lieben freunde stuttgart los
russischer schaffen plus comedy sascha
trussardi ich wusste nicht dass
russische wurzeln hat ja hellinger ist
jetzt auch nicht so der russische name
für mich ziemlich deutschland habe sogar
der erste youtuber war schon in mehreren
fernsehshows zu sehen heiratete seinen
blauen vegas um nennt sich selbst könig
wir haben gerade noch davon gesprochen
mir sind wie gesagt ich setze meine
prioritäten einfach anders du bist
einfach mal lesen in ruhe ich will
einfach dass sie wieder ein schönes foto
hat und das ist der fall ja ok ja
schreibe ich das nicht anja
youtube
bei funkkanal plus gelegen hatte
also wo immer du immer so am vorlesen
nicht so ohne vorlesen vielleicht ist es
gar nicht wenn man ein schönes foto von
rewe ja
hatte eine band italienische wurzeln war
gut mit ihm befreundet
unique user
hat er eine band italienische wurzeln
und war gut miteinander befreundet ich
gar nichts
der boss der bosse
spricht deutsch englisch italienisch und
französisch hatte eine nasen-op cosplay
fan anita tack
hey
hat er eine nasen-op und spricht deutsch
englisch italienisch und französisch
nach hause und überlegt was ja ich bin
fällt niemand ein ist das an die ja
ich wusste auch nicht dass sie eine
nasen-op hatte aber cosplay konnte für
mich nur an i sein
ausbildung zum erzieher simon l
da damit bislang war das portugiesische
insel
ich wollte lp midcaps sagen ich weiß
nicht warum ich darauf gekommen ein
bisschen leid dass ich hier alles
zuläuft ich sagen sobald
wir haben kanal sollen zuschauern poesie
liebe und zuneigung geben gromit am
erfolgen sarrazin doria kanal mit ihrem
enkel marmeladen oma
eigene modekollektion justin fitness den
sco kommt aus stuttgart ihr in skopje
so jetzt die letzten drei runden bekommt
man für jede runde 100 punkte okay das
ist jetzt 100 zuhörer jetzt jahrhundert
zu helfen
ich führe gerade ja es geht wieder um
100 punkte ursprünglich aus hamburg
wandert gerne in hannover
schweiz er kommt ursprünglich aus
hamburg vorletzte runde runde nummer
neuen schwarzer humor tv
hersteller mini gut
v
der krieg war das nicht mit der
die karte hat das war mit der maschine
krieg war auf dem video des auftritts
ach so stimmt
letzte runde meine lieben freunde seit
2010 kelly youtube aktiv ursprünglich
aus bayern und song namens klicken das
ist würde ich sagen hey i missed this
blog sage ich du sagst ich sage muss ich
wieder
wir sind gespannt wer es jetzt sein wird
und es
heja für krawall gut meine lieben
freunde das war erkennst du die youtuber
an drei merkmalen ein bisschen oldschool
max ich habe es ja früher öfters mal
gebracht und bei max ging auch ein video
davon online oder ging das schon unseren
max absolut gar keine ahnung wenn ich
das so klar
[Musik]